yeah uh you also have access to chat
send it to all panelists and we'll see
it
if you're watching on the live stream
abandon so uh nine questions for for us
comments
once again and you can see how to end
this stream we'll have people relay
those to us okay so we also have a
couple of questions
thank you guys let's start with this
first and two-part question
is
uh just to give us a gauge of how much
experience people have in the audience
and
we also asked
check in on how you're doing
we've been asking that since the
pandemic started because
all been in a confusing time with surges
coming and going and lockdowns happening
and
hopefully we're past that mostly but I
wanted to check to see how people are
doing today
so we'll keep this open for another six
seconds or so
share the answers with you
and we have an interesting distribution
here uh issues you probably see um
you've got about a third of the audience
has more than five years of experience
um and about uh 55 57 of the audience uh
under two years including people who are
at University still so
um it's also good to see that
almost everybody's doing well or okay
today so that's that's good encouraging
yeah
um
so just to introduce yourself to the
folks I've put up this slide but maybe
you can talk a little bit about
your background
well
just start a conversation yeah thank you
Stuart uh so I am ayushi Mishra I'm
currently working as a an assistant
manager at CTS Tech so I had joined this
company uh a few months back around 10
months back in January to 2022. and uh
my profile here is mostly into data
science uh the technical side of the
data science and I work as a data
science specialist for my organization I
have worked with a different machine
learning problems uh deep learning
problems and in various domains like
healthcare I have worked with a
mechanical engineering so like Metrology
and Automobiles and Retail sector as
well so those are the different areas
that I have worked with and my ID sector
experiences around uh around seven years
now and uh
yeah that is all that is our problem for
my introduction so I hope we'll have a
good discussion today and I'll be
helpful in any way possible
thank you so much yeah and you know what
we're going to be talking about today is
uh you know kind of some of your
experience in your recent
career transition
um it's the before you were working in
uh before you began began working at
Sidious where had you been uh so I
worked with an organization uh called
renisha Metrology so it is uh Metrology
domain sector uh domain so where they
mostly deal with the automobiles part so
the mechanical engineering side of uh of
uh of the I.T sector so but because they
are building machines and uh they are
they have their clients who use those
software so they needed uh some analysis
tools
that's where I worked in that uh and I
started my journey as a as a data
scientist so it was uh in the research
and development department of that
company so
yeah uh how did you choose to get into
data science and you've been in software
engineering before that or or did you
always
have a background in data science or an
interest in data science okay that is a
very nice question so I guess uh I uh
there the percentage of people who
actually start their career as a data
scientist or in the field of data
science as per my experience is very low
most of the people that I have come
across most of the people that I have
worked with have transitioned their
career into data science so that has
been my experience till now I too have
worked as a software developer
previously but
my interest in data size started during
when I was pursuing my masters so that's
where we uh it was the data science
domain that was a very buzzword during
that time so it has started to Boom up
like data science everywhere and people
were looking going into Python and R and
data analysis and everything so we even
our the curriculum that we were
following following so they also
included data science in their uh in the
courses so that's where the interest
started building up so I did my research
the project which I worked on in mass in
my Master's so that was uh somehow
started uh uh was based in data science
not completely but a few part of that
and then I fully functionally uh when I
started uh working in the in my previous
organization I switched to the data
science profile there so but there also
I worked as an application developer
first but because I was interested in
our data science and I was already
working I already had some experience in
data science so I switched my profile in
that and that was a very big change very
big shift in terms of the uh the type of
thinking the type of approach that we
take in terms of how we are solving the
problems how we are looking at the
problems and solutions that we are
trying to bring it up so uh that's how I
switched into data science
okay that's an interesting brings up an
interesting subject for
people in the audience I think are here
because they're interested in how they
might structure their job search or
their career Transitions and advancement
when you made the change in your
previous organization from software
engineering into data science was there
a formal process there where you had to
interview with new managers and
go through a process internally
I guess uh when you do the switch
internally uh
there is not that much of a process uh
but yes it is a requirement it is a
prerequisite that you should be aware of
the of the of the Technologies of the
concepts of the models uh and of the
different uh tools that you are going to
work on so I guess that is the
requirement in any job that you are
applying for you need to have some basic
concepts clear you need to have uh some
of the tech aware of some of the
Technologies and the tools uh that for
the job that you are applying for so
that is a prerequisite I guess for every
job uh so that is the only thing uh
which was required and uh
uh as I guess that what we see in any
job so you learn as you start working
for that project so the problems that
that you're working on will be very
specific to those projects for to for
that organization or for the clients
that you're working on so it is always a
learning process so it is same for all
the uh in any domain you work with so it
is the similar uh the difference is that
uh the base that you're that you should
be familiar with so the models uh so
like I'll I'll we'll talk about I guess
in uh
here uh in the future right uh yeah so
the models that we the models that you
are going to work on so the basic
concepts you should be aware of so that
is the only requirement I guess so so
otherwise uh it is a it is pretty much
easier to switch internally uh that that
has been my experience so it is easier
to switch internally as compared to when
you look out for the jobs outside
yeah and one of the advantages with an
internal transition is that the company
already knows you
um they know your your style and that
you fit in with the company culture and
that type of thing so the the process of
evaluation focuses more on can you do
this new job
again as you said you've got a track
record internally so that people can see
the kind of work you do and then they
just have to to connect that to the new
type of work that you're trying to do so
it's a different process though when
you're going to switch companies or when
you're entering the workforce so
um first off
what was it like when you made the
decision what was it that attracted you
to
uh the idea of switching to a different
company maybe looking for a higher
position
yes okay so the idea to switch to a new
into a new company was the kind of
projects that I have been working on so
as I said it was uh basically a
mechanical company and the projects that
we were working on were very uh the
scope of those projects were very
limited in terms of the models that we
were using in terms of the uh the
complete software packages that we were
building so it was more or less the
problem statement that we were trying to
solve even though they were different
from different customers to from
different customers but the approach was
similar the the uh the background was
similar and the kind of uh problems were
similar so uh after some time uh
the learning process it kind of become
monotonous so that was the base basic
motivation for trying to when I decided
that I should look outside so just to
get an uh get a change in the in the
kind of problems in the kind of
uh
solutions that we should work on so that
was the base uh basic motivation behind
that okay
um and how did you come across Sidious
as a potential employer uh okay so I
guess uh I did not apply that company so
the recruitment team uh approached me
for uh their opening yeah so uh it was a
uh the interview uh all in all it was um
it was good and uh the the thing that
was uh uh which what I was looking for
was the kind of projects that they were
working on and whether those projects
are getting utilized so the the main
problem with data science domain is that
no matter how many models we build no
matter uh how much work we do if those
models that we are building is not
getting utilized in any way uh
there is no uh I have what the term I'm
not I'm not able to get that term so
I think the word is satisfaction I think
right right right exactly so when you
work in the soft when you work in
software development so though that
software is getting built by for a
specific purpose but when you are
working in data science you are to
convince the business uh that uh why it
is useful to use our models because it
is uh all about uh analysis it is all
about prediction like it is it is going
to predict it is how it is going to
predict it is very difficult to convince
people like uh uh like uh so you will
use a model it will be predicting with
this much probability so like they will
not be sure like should we use the model
should we not use the model how it is
going to help them so to convince the
people to use those models it is a very
difficult task and uh because they are
already automated processes or for all
the businesses that are uh I guess for
all the companies the businesses are all
already automated so why the use of data
models why why do we do extra work and
why should we use those models Implement
those models and teach those how to you
teach those more but you uh people to
use those models so uh if the projects
uh you are working on they should be
getting used in some way so that is uh
the main uh that is the question that I
ask people I used to ask the
interviewers so like if we are working
on on a data science problem is it
getting used anywhere so that's that's
where you get to uh analyze like uh
whether you the work that you will be
doing will be getting utilized and uh
will be seen somewhere we will be
getting used somewhere in any way
yeah and that that's an important
element of job satisfaction because
when you feel that you're doing
something that helps your employer that
helps your field of work or that helps
people in general
um then you have the satisfaction of
knowing that you're you're contributing
yes and and the opposite happens when
you put effort into something and it
doesn't get used and you feel like
why did I do that I'm not contributing
anything to anybody even though I'm
working hard and I'm doing my job well
if it's not resulting in
Improvement or decision or that type of
thing that can be that can be
frustrating so but you touch on a really
interesting aspect of
what happens with people especially who
have
current positions and are are in out in
the Working World
you may get calls from recruiters you
may get calls from people who are
actively seeking to fill positions they
may have seen your
CV on some job board or they they may
have heard about you in some other way
they may just have looked at your
LinkedIn profile and then they contact
you
so there's an aspect of interviewing
touched on where you start by
interviewing the recruiter so they've
come to you they've said here's this job
you might be a good fit for it and so
when you initiate that process
are you more concerned were you more
concerned with
um presenting yourself to the recruiter
as a valuable candidate or were you did
you start by asking well wait a minute
why am I going to listen to you about
this position in this company
which came first that kind of thing okay
initially uh I'll try to be as honest as
possible so initially I tried to present
myself uh to be a valuable candidate and
like I have I know all these things I
have worked on these things but I
realized that when you uh spend time and
energy preparing for that particular
role particular profile for that
particular interview and then uh after
the interview you realize that the job
that you're looking for is not that the
what the interviewer is expecting or
what the requirement is so that has
happened a lot of time so because
initially the what the mistake I I'll
call it my mistake that I was not very
much prepared to ask the recruiter about
exactly the about the job specification
like what will be the roles and
responsibilities of uh of this
particular role so uh but while
interviewing it was very clear like
where uh the interviewer was going in
the process so was it more into the data
science profile or as a software
developer profile so uh that's where it
becomes helpful when you uh uh while
enter interacting with a recruiter so
the issue what lies there is because
they are not from the technical profile
so they can only give out some of the
information like the technologies that
have that they are mentioning okay so
what are things that they are what are
technologies that they are looking for
so it gives you an idea but it really is
helpful when uh during the interview
process it's better to ask the
interviewer uh about the role and
responsibilities for that particular job
so it will be helpful
for you for uh our uh for the
interviewee as well so whether they are
looking actually looking for that
profile or not like if you are if you
are only uh focusing to uh to switch in
the data science domain so so it is uh I
don't think so it is relevant to uh give
interviews for uh for a python developer
who has knowledge about data science so
it because the data science is a huge
huge domain and it is most of the time
it is not clear the requirements are not
clear with the recruiters so while when
they they are just mentioning all the
tech tools and Technologies I guess so
whatever they can come across so it is
still not clear with the recruiters like
what do they actually want
so it's better to focus on what you want
and uh it's it saves your time I guess
in in short uh to uh know about the
roles and the tools and Technologies and
the profile that you are interviewing
for
it's a little bit different when you're
looking at for example a job listing on
a job board or that type of thing uh
when you come across a direct listing
from a company you may still it may
still be a listing from a recruiter and
then you have to go through that level
but
um
then you have the opportunity to do a
little pre and
analysis or pre Judgment of whether this
is a suitable
opportunity for you whether this is the
type of work that you want to do
um what about looking at the company
itself when you when you heard that this
was a position with uh Sidious had you
ever heard of them before
yes I I had I I did have heard about
them before yeah
no I was just going to say um
you had a a presume a favorable
impression of the company already
um did you need to do more
Research into the company and what it
does and what your role might be
um
as you were preparing for for the
pretty process the hiring process
uh I guess Steward it is always uh good
to know about the company that you are
going to interview for it is all it is I
guess it is one of the best practices to
uh know and research about the company
that you are going to interview for
because it gives you an idea about the
kind of questions that you might expect
the kind of answers that you will give
in the interview so like most of the
questions that are uh that I have come
across for from different uh come from
different interviewers are the pro kind
of problems that they are facing uh
currently in their business problems or
in the in the projects that they are
working on so it is uh specifically uh
based on uh the domain that they are
working on so if it is a semiconductor
based company so they'll they'll
approach you with the kind of questions
that are relevant to them uh if it like
currently I'm working in healthcare
domain so they'll they the interview
will ask questions that are about
problems that they are facing currently
in their in their projects and in their
organization so it is always good to go
for and research about the companies
that you are going to interview for
um
yeah it also gives you an idea of about
how you will answer our to that question
so so uh if you are not from that domain
so like I'm I'm working in healthcare
but I was not aware of about the
healthcare domain so I I the best thing
that I could do was Google about the
company and the kind of projects that
they are building and uh some of the the
key terms and so even if I'm not aware
about exactly what they're working on I
can get an idea about what they are
asking so it helps in answering and
framing the questions uh answers uh
around those questions yeah right
so that's excellent advice on you know
being able to understand the company the
domain that it works in
um understanding both aspects of
how they work specifically but also how
the the domain
you know what the problems are that
they're going to have to solve in that
area and being able to go in and sound
knowledgeable about those areas when you
talk to the people in the interviews
um so when you interviewed
with Insidious and you started talking
to the people from that company rather
than just the recruiter that brought you
in
um what was the first round of
interviews what was the first type of
interview
okay so uh the first kind of interview
so it depends upon company to companies
because uh data science uh again uh I'll
go with the the kind of problems that
they are solving in the company
sometimes uh so for CTS Tech it was uh a
technical interview round that is the
first round but it wasn't of the coding
type you do not have to code you the
technical interview will answer
interviewer will ask questions about the
kind of projects that you have worked on
previously uh the kind of problems that
you have faced in those projects uh and
what was my uh role and responsibilities
in that project so uh it starts with
with the basic questions like uh like
what I said right now and uh then it
goes into more technical uh uh depth of
the in depth of the of the uh of the
problems that I have I've been working
on so like the modeling part and how
much time was spent in the modeling part
and what are the models that you have
used and then about the concepts the
basic concepts of data science like
probability statistics the data science
models and the different kinds of models
that I have worked with and what are the
shortcomings and all these kinds of
technical questions that are involved in
data science so this was the interview
process for CTS Tech but uh I can uh but
with my experience with other companies
who they also focus on the coding side
of uh for the interview so uh it is
mostly uh so it's not that because
because this was the uh process for this
company but it doesn't mean that it will
be the same for all the companies so uh
like I have uh there are some companies
who follow the process like they'll uh
provide you a data set and they'll give
you a time for a few days and you will
have to build come up with the solution
solution in terms of the model output so
you'll have to build a model for that
particular data set and you'll have to
explain what you have built in for the
next round of discussion other kind of
interview the first round is is purely
about the python coding so that does not
involve data science at all that does
tests your knowledge about the coding
like python codes it might be of any
level like e0 easier medium or hard
based on the kind of problems that they
are solving in the in the organization
so if it if they're solving an
optimization problem so there you have
to have a good coding strength in any
language so that is languages I I don't
think so language was ever a concern
while interviewing for data science jobs
so but mostly people prefer Python and R
because if you are working for data
science so yeah
and you you brought up the notion that
you know some of the interviews are
talking about show us projects you have
done and being able to explain those
what the approach was why you chose a
particular uh model or or type of
approach over another
um how you implemented that type of
thing and then you also mentioned that
there are sometimes challenges where
they give you a problem to solve and
watch you solve it or what have you come
back with a solution and your answer
um
when you were looking at uh
your your job search
were you able to find advice from people
who had interviewed with that company
before or were you able to get advice
from the recruiter that said these are
the kind this is the way we're going to
structure that first level of technical
interview
were you able to prepare it that way
um no I I did not get to have it touch
with any of the people who were working
with that company before
uh so uh but I have people I have
colleagues and I have friends who are
working in the data science domain so
that is a very that becomes very helpful
when you are interviewing for different
jobs because they you get an extra
perspective of what you are working on
so like if the interviewer is uh giving
us a project and we have to work on that
project so uh we it might not be
possible it might be that that that
particular problem is uh is what they
are facing right now in the the problem
that they are facing right now that they
have uh asked for solution or it might
be to get a general idea of how I am I
will be up approaching to that
particular problem it doesn't matter
if I'm able to get to a particular
solution or if to a good solution so but
they try to analyze in the first process
like what should what is the approach
what is the approach that the interview
is taking to get to that particular
solution and what uh what is the
approach of solving the problems that if
the the uh that might be there in the in
the problem statement
um
that
that you know brings up an interesting
point about that that question which is
you know how do you find other people
who are involved oh do you talk about
having a colleague or somebody who's
been there and that's one of the nice
things about
today's discussion is you're somebody
who's been there so people in the
audience today get a little bit of
benefit from your experience and um so
thank you for for sharing that with it
um there's also you know if you can find
people who are working at the company if
you can find people who have worked at
the company or other discussion boards
from people who are you know
um those are all kinds of resources that
people can look at you've gone through
the technical interview round is it more
than one round with different
interviewers before you get to the next
level
or is it you went through with one
technical evaluator and they said yes
are you she's good to go
um
let's move her to the next step of the
process
uh I am no Stuart it's always at least
two or three rounds of interviews so
first is act either the coding round or
uh or the project round what we say then
the next round is always if you have
built a project so you have to explain
the project that you have built or
explain the project uh that the projects
that you have worked on so that is that
is what's what's mostly covered in the
technical round then comes the
managerial round who where the manager
is trying to analyze if you are good fit
for their team so you have to work uh so
the the questions that are there framed
there will be technical definitely the
the manager in the management around the
technical interviews are there but not
from uh uh from a single person's
perspective but as for uh from the
team's perspective like uh what's this
the size of the team that you have
worked with or uh how did you uh Bill
used to solve these problems uh so what
was the hierarchy or what was the uh
what was your role as as a particular as
a team member and how did you Mentor if
you were mentoring any people or if how
it was it your what is was a client
facing or were you facing your customers
was how what kind of role was that so uh
there the analysis is of that sort of uh
from that perspective what uh but that
too includes the technical uh questions
from the manager from the managerial
round yeah yeah that there as you
described it you're they're looking more
also at the soft skills that you have in
terms of communication in terms of
interpersonal
management and
your ability to
take Direction your ability to give
direction your willingness to help your
team members and help them Advance or
teach them new knowledge
um so that those are all
important types of skills that people
may ask you about or may be looking for
an information like that and
uh
you you talked about
in in one particular example
here's a initial round of looking at
um
the skills you have And discussing those
another round of looking at projects in
detail
and then moving on to the managerial
was there a
next stop after that where maybe they
took you and said okay here's the
department head and we just want to
introduce you and and see how you fit or
how many layers of of interviewing
did you encounter yeah so uh in my
experience is uh the the decision making
round stopped after I guess three rounds
uh but yes we do uh connect with the
departmental heads or the delivery leads
of that of the projects but that is uh
not a decision making round that is just
for uh the get to know your uh leaders
or get to know your uh they from their
perspective get to know the team members
who are who will join the team so that
is more from there that perspective but
not from the decision making perspective
yeah great so in in that case in your
case it was
once you got to that level the decision
to hire you had pretty much been made
and this was just an orientation
um in other situations uh of course
there's there's always there's
the potential that somebody at the at
that
managerial or leadership
round has a veto over the decision so
that they can say Okay I I see why you
like this candidate but I have these
concerns so
um you need to be prepared
not to treat that level as oh I've got
the job I'm just meeting you as a
formality you still have to treat that
as I need to make a good impression on
the person who will be my my boss or my
boss's boss yes definitely and and so
are there particular things that you
would advise you know you talked about
being able to hopefully intelligently
talk about experience with python with
our
um
with Statistics with modeling techniques
are there other particular things
phrases buzzwords keywords that uh
you're aware of that people should have
in their mind
when they're preparing for for
interviews in the data science team
uh okay so uh other than the
Technologies the language that we are
that we are we are working on so mostly
it is uh python like 95 percent of the
times uh the recruiters ask for either
python or R so uh R is useful uh so in
my experience R is useful when you're
when you are not from the actual coding
background so like when you have not uh
uh from the computer science or IT
background and uh and you do not have
that much uh
uh strength you your strength is not the
coding so R is very was very useful in
for for those uh people who are trying
uh to get into the data science domain
and so that our uh for that purpose R is
very useful when if you are but mostly
what I have uh seen is like uh people
prefer uh recruiters prefer uh uh python
uh when for developing their models so
because it is a very easy language easy
to understand easy to learn and easy to
implement so there are huge libraries in
Python so uh and mostly out of that uh
for data science what we use are sklearn
like for traditional data science
problems SQL the libraries that you
should be aware of are SQL and uh pandas
numpy so all these are the basic
libraries that you should be aware of
that we are using in data science uh the
other things that uh that everyone
should be aware of the probability
problems so uh the statistics statistics
is the basic of mathematics so uh the
questions that you will come across will
be very basic like uh uh the mean median
mode so it might be as as simple as that
like what is what is what is the central
tendency theorem and for that the next
level goes through the probability so
conditional probability questions so I
I don't think so that uh but yeah that I
have faced uh that many questions
related to statistics and probability
but yes that is uh I guess everybody
should be aware about the basics of data
science so that's where the data science
that's where data science starts uh uh
statistic because uh for the analysis
purposes so statistics and probability
and statistics are the are the base when
you are going for analysis and when you
are uh uh justifying uh the the results
that you are getting after after
modeling so those are uh are the keys
key areas that you should be very much
aware of uh other than modeling uh other
things that uh one should take care of
are the different
um what I can say the terms uh that uh
that they mentioned so see data science
as I said so it's a huge umbrella and
the the recruiters they try to uh put
all the technologies that they are aware
of uh all the all the tools that they
that are related to data science but uh
it doesn't mean that if you are applying
for that particular job like if I am
particularly applying for that
particular job I should be aware of all
the like if they have mentioned 100
Technologies then I should I should be
knowing all those hundred uh
Technologies it's it's not like that I
guess because more like what I have uh
seen is uh people usually use four or
five out of them but they are mentioning
everything so like uh if it is a data
science a typical data science job and
they are mentioning uh Docker they are
mentioning Kafka they are mentioning Pi
spark they are mentioning everything
that they that they think that data
science has so but I but I never found
that there using those Technologies they
will be using either one of them and
even if you are aware of one of those
Technologies it is easy to learn the
other Technologies as well but you
should be Keen to learn those that's all
I I that that has been my experience as
of now uh other thing is that uh in
addition to data science in addition to
machine learning the keywords that are
mentioned are NLP so natural language
processing and computer vision so uh
there are different different areas of
data science as well so like currently I
the problem statements that I am working
all working uh on are traditional data
science problem so you will get a proper
SQL database you will get numbers from
that and from those numbers you are
building a model prediction model
regression model different kinds of
models but I have worked with problem
statements where the data is not a table
not in the formatted the database table
it is images so for image images you
need to know different algorithms so
which come under data science but it is
not actually machine learning problems
it is not classification regression it
is a classification regression but a
different kind of classification
regression so that for that for those
images you will need deep learning
algorithms so you should while looking
while looking at the job requirements
the technologies that that are getting
mentioned it is important to see like
whether it is a image processing so they
may those keywords are getting mentioned
there so and for it is totally different
for natural language processing so
natural language processing there are
different uh approaches different
libraries in Python different uh kinds
of solutions that you are looking for so
I do I so personally like I have worked
in all these three problem statements
but I can say for sure that I am not
very confident in natural language
processing but if the require even if
the profile says it is is of data
science the recruiter is saying that the
profile is of data science but it might
include natural language processing
which I am not very confident in so I
should think I what I do is I think
about it like do I need to do I need to
go ahead with this or am I confident
enough or uh uh I am I willing to work
for natural language processing because
I personally don't find natural language
processing very uh good for me I don't
like NLP so uh yes so I prefer tradition
either traditional data science or deep
learning uh kind of job job requirement
so those are the things that you should
be focusing on while while when you're
looking for those keywords the the the
job requirements that are mentioned the
tools and technologies that I mentioned
yeah right and and you make a a very
important point where
the job description may include
a whole raft of different Technologies
and
may sound like you need to know all of
these in order to be at all qualified
for the job
but in fact
you need to do a little bit of digging
to find out
which of those are just being thrown in
as
let's just put in everything or which of
those are actual parts of the job that
you're going to really have to do there
was a
report I heard on the local radio here
that talked about
diversity and equity and
technology and they were talking about
the fact that women are underrepresented
in cyber security in Silicon Valley
environment
um and they said one of the reasons was
that when I
male applicant sees a job description
and they say oh I've got 30 percent of
the things that they mentioned I may as
well take a shot at this
position they'll put in an application
but when female applicants look at that
job description and they see well I've
only got 30 percent of the things that
they're asking for I'm not possibly
qualified for it and they won't put it
in it and the the point that the the
answer was making or that the expert was
making
the interview was
of course you should put in the
application because
that the 30 percent that you have may be
what they're looking for and the rest of
it may just be filler that they just put
in to cover themselves
um so always
and you look at something like that
don't necessarily don't necessarily edit
yourself out until you've done a little
bit more digging to find out what is the
real requirement for the job and what
are the actual sets of skills for it and
as you said even when um maybe the
actual set of skills need something
where you're a little bit weak are you
honestly willing to commit to learning
about that and improving yourself so
that you can say I don't know that but
that part very well
but I am willing to learn it
my track record shows that when I decide
I'm going to learn something yes I do
accomplish it so that's a really good
thing for people to know when they're
out there looking
jobs
um we're reaching a point now where I'm
going to go to the questions and the
answers I don't think we need to um
put up a slide for that but uh I'm gonna
see if I can pull out
some of the things that have been coming
through in the chat and the Q a box and
we had uh for example Rahul asks you
know he's from a pharmaceutical sales
background he has seven years of
experience what is the likelihood that
somebody would consider somebody with
his background for a data science
position
and what would he need to do in order to
be able to qualify for that
okay pharmaceutical sales background uh
so Rahul I guess uh for if you want to
enter the data science domain uh the
best approach is to learn coding and
learn data science so I guess there are
wonderful certification programs that
are available you can analyze you can
try I guess simply learn itself is
providing programs for data science the
basic requirement to get into data
science is that you need to have a
coding experience and you need to have a
data science experience so you can
definitely uh get into this domain uh
and uh as per uh my experience uh so I
have uh worked with people who are from
uh not from the engineering background
uh uh from but uh from different uh like
uh BSC or MSC but they are getting into
data science so I guess a background is
not an issue here uh you just need to
have the proper qualification proper uh
requirements that uh for the profile
that you are applying for
yeah and
one aspect of rahul's question is that
he's in
um a pharmaceutical background
so one of the aspects that is domain
knowledge of the pharmaceutical industry
medical industry General is going to
help him when he's looking at positions
in that sector so that may be uh one
thing
yes that will be an added Advantage
because uh if you are if you apply in
the healthcare domain so a
pharmaceutical or in the pharmaceutical
domain particularly so that will be the
domain knowledge is uh I guess it's a
it's it trumps all the if if even if you
are not uh from the uh data science
background or engineering background or
coding background so domain knowledge is
I guess yes it will be very helpful yeah
if you've got if you you if you get the
basic skills uh to cover
the technical aspects the main knowledge
can be a big deciding factor for you uh
we have
murali and our LinkedIn audience wants a
full stack Java developer job so talk in
the future uh webinar about that in fact
I think we have one next week
talk about interviewing tips for
software but back in data science
um
Newton LinkedIn audience says I have a
business analysis background
um
I'm found knowledge of Technology how
then do I become a data scientist what's
the path head for that
okay
okay great uh um I guess uh it is a
similar same to similar to what I
explained just now so to get into data
science it I guess a good certification
course is um uh
is I guess it is enough and you when you
work when you get a certification for
data science uh you try to learn about
the different uh uh the projects that
you work on the different technologies
that you will be using so all those
things you will that will get covered
under those certification programs I
guess uh you will get a very good idea
about or how data science how data
science works so it is uh not just about
coding so if you if you are actually uh
working in data science it is more more
about how you approach a problem and
what you are trying to solve and what
other results that you are expecting the
goals you are trying to achieve it is a
it is a process of uh of approaching a
problem which is how it is different
from a typical software development
where you are building uh building a
software just a software so like if you
really uh if you are interested into
getting into data science I get a good
certification course uh where you can
analyze you can uh Google it uh that
will be very helpful helpful so that's
what I did so I got a certification code
certification course for data science
and but because but I did long time back
so uh the online programs weren't
available at that time so and they were
not very popular at that time like like
how they are right now so this is a very
this is an advantage I'll say like right
now because of the online programs who
are
um very much appreciate appreciated in
all the companies and if you if you
mentioned that that to them that you are
you have done this so and so uh course
certification course for data science so
that is appreciated by the recruiters as
well so uh if you do that if you if you
work on an actual case study on an
actual problem statement and you you
will get to know how to solve a problem
how how the problems are getting solved
uh in data science so that that will
make it easier to switch your career
into data science
okay I think that addresses a question
from AJ who is asking how you know how
to make your
profile look more attractive in data
science if you're in a different field
or
if you're a fresher another question
came in so the advice of
a
certification in B Project work
um
do you find things like open source
projects and hackathons and things like
that give you opportunities or are there
other places that you would look to get
experience like that uh okay so uh for
project work looks like if it is only
for the learning purpose I guess there
are lots and lots of videos available on
YouTube free of course so you can go
through all the all the videos of the
projects so that uh that will help you
get an understanding how it is
implemented how people are approaching
towards that particular problem but for
your practice it is always helpful to
practice those projects yourself rather
than just learning from uh YouTube or
watching videos or about that so I guess
kaggle organizes lots and lots of
hackathons there or they have their own
data sets and the problem statements
mentioned there you can pick up pick it
up uh from kaggle you can pick it up
from uh there are different uh data set
sources for available online and
everything I guess everything is free of
course you can pick it up uh any project
that you you that interests you and you
can start working on that and uh the the
the size of the data set so uh the
problem is that when we are when we have
a personal laptops we uh it is a bit of
a challenge in terms of the uh
specifications of the laptop when we are
training the model so it requires a
higher specification higher specs or uh
in terms of GPU or the if if you if you
have CPU so you need a higher end of CPU
so uh you can pick up a small size of
data sets just for your practice
purposes so that will not be an issue
but you will get more confidence when
you start Pro solving those problems
yourselves rather than just view uh uh
watching videos about or watching uh the
problems getting solved so participation
yes so use you can start with kaggle you
can pick up data sets there you can
start uh building those problems
yourself and there are
discussion forums there as well so if
you come across any problems you can ask
for help on different discussion forums
as well
question about cloud computing Cloud
engineering but I think we also have
other webinars and resources that you
can check out from Simply learn about
that domain
um
when we're looking at uh data science is
there
YouTube audience asks
what's the distinction between a data
scientist and a data analyst
okay
yes uh so the basic difference between a
data scientist and a data analyst is uh
the data analyst uh does not get
involved uh in the model building part
of the uh project so the uh the roles
and responsibilities of a data analysis
data analysts are limited towards uh the
exploration of the data so if you are
given a data you need to explore that
data into in any terms from any num any
number of perspectives and you need to
get the results in terms of how
how the data looks how like in terms of
percentages in terms of uh different
statistics output but when it comes to
data science uh it is mostly about the
uh the model building part like if you
are you are trying to build a model that
will predict so and so things you are
trying to build a model that will uh
give you a result of uh what will be the
outcome of
if like for example if I'm saying so
whether it will rain or not uh be given
on these these parameters so you are
building a model a machine learning
model that will train the data that uh
and it will provide the solution of
prediction what you call so all those
kinds of problems how to deal with uh
those uh kinds of approaches so that is
what is dealt with under the data
science profile uh data analysis is very
much I guess limited to the exploration
of the data part not it does not involve
the modeling part of data science
um we have a question that I think
touches on your particular background as
well which is uh
Balman from the YouTube audience asks
how is data science and ml helpful for
somebody in a mechanical engineering
domain and background and what kind of
path should
take to move into data science
so as I mentioned earlier so the
background does not matter when you uh
when you try to enter data science even
yes the domain knowledge helps a lot so
like I have worked for a Metrology
company which usually works uh with
mechanical engineers so because the
softwares that they are developing so
the domain knowledge helps a lot uh so
there uh when the when the project for
data science when it started so it uh
the domain knowledge helped a lot depend
based on the kind of data that we were
getting and uh uh because it was a bit
difficult to understand like what uh
what we are looking at it was it was not
clear uh if we are not from the
mechanical engineering background so uh
domain knowledge is always helpful when
you try to enter data science data
science is not restricted to any any
domain I guess so as per my experience I
have lots and lots of people my friends
my colleagues who are not from the
engineering background were not from the
actual coding uh computer science and IT
background and who are working as data
science data scientists so uh I hope I
answered your question so and I have
been yeah I have been saying that if you
want to enter data science it will be
good if you uh if you are if you think
that you can study by yourself and you
can uh you have that approach of solving
the data science question so data
science problems uh it will be easier uh
to do that but a certification uh in
these days when you are looking for jobs
a good certification course all always
helps yeah and it's kind of uh
some people are able to do these kinds
of things on their own without a
guide
um but most people I think find it
easier to do it when somebody is acting
as their guided Mentor or crying in the
process
um
I think last two questions because we're
coming up on our hour but um
Ahmed asks are there forums or websites
that you can point to or recommend for
somebody to
kind of get a feel for data science or
keep track of what's going on or
see what data scientist Practitioner
Data science practitioners are
discussing with each other
kinds of
subreddits or
other forms or websites
okay for uh
not as per my knowledge I'm not sure
about that but I do whenever I am facing
uh
any problem so I I do find my Solutions
on on Google so I I that's what that's
the best thing that I I could I can
think of right now I I never came across
any discussion forums like uh where data
scientists are looking for problems or
discussing problems other than kaggle
other than kaggle so it the data science
problems are very much specific to the
problems that a particular project is
facing so that's what uh I have come
across so uh it is very much similar to
like what software software developers
do they post their problems on stack
Overflow they get the they get their
answers there their queries is all there
so that is what the people from data
science do so
there are no but there are lots and lots
of good
reading material if you if you want so
there are available online uh it's like
medium.com there uh they the the Thai
the kind of way that they are explaining
the problems the explaining the theorems
explaining uh the models the concepts
the basic concepts of the models which
are very important to understand when
you are using uh uh those models in your
problem statement trying to understand
your model straight uh understand the
problem and actually using those models
so you need to understand the the basic
concept of those models like what is
that model doing how why it is working
this way and how it is working this way
and why we are using that particular
problem and not the other any other
model why we are particularly using that
model what are those advantages of those
models so all those uh things are
explained really well so that is for the
the for personal reading not uh
that is not related to any course or
certification but that is those all
those things help you get a better
understanding of uh the kind of uh
things that you are working on right
okay we had a whole bunch of questions
for people of different uh domain
backgrounds Tech backgrounds outside of
data science and I think you already
answered
a few of the the types of questions so I
think hopefully they'll be able to apply
those answers to their particular
situations I want to ask the last
question and I apologize to everyone
whose questions we could not get to
there are so many here
um people are extremely interested in
this data science is very interesting
yeah
but in especially what you've you've had
to say today issue because uh people
have expressed personal thanks to you in
the chat here but
um but the last question I want to ask
is what tips would you give to college
students
um who are looking to move ahead to data
science what what steps do they take it
well they're still in school
okay so very great question even my
sister is uh right now in college and
I'm I'm trying to help her get into data
science so uh so far in terms of uh the
expectations from a fresher by the
recruiters so it is very much similar to
how you appear for any other job profile
but for for reporting for the data
science domain so it is um uh I'm not
sure about how how if the companies if
there are campus placements uh where the
where the recruiters are offering their
Pro Data science uh profile to freshers
but uh there are lots and lots of
opportunities you will find on LinkedIn
um they uh I I come across lots of
opportunities myself which are there for
freshers so it will be good if you uh
try to look at those uh the requirements
from those profiles and it is always
very uh
it was it will always help you to work
on a simple project so even if you are
not working on a huge project you do not
have industry experience but you can
anytime go on Google you can you can
anytime log into kaggle you can uh pick
up a data set you there are lots and
lots of problem statements available on
kaggle you can try and work on that uh
as a project and you will uh yourself
come across uh the challenges that you
will face while while dealing with those
problems so that will be very helpful
and that will help you in the interviews
that you will give uh when you come out
of come out of college
excellent thank you so much for that and
um
going to go ahead
as we go back to the slides here I'm
going to go ahead we've just finished
the questions and answers and again I
apologize to everyone whose questions we
could not get to I'm going to mention
one of the certification programs that
simply learn is introduced and this
one's different we have a number of
different data science certification
programs this one happens to be tailored
to uh Learners in India specifically
because what we've done is partnered
with a number of companies
in India today
who have agreed to basically hire as
many people as we can graduate from this
program
so this program gives you a
comprehensive
background it gives you live virtual
classes so you meet online weekly with
instructors
a online classroom environment so you
can ask the instructor get lesson watch
lesson live and and also introduce
interact with your peers in the class
it gives you a platform to do your data
science exercises and projects right on
the learning management system so you
don't need to to create a separate test
bed or project
platform for yourself
um but again it
six months where you devote 10 to 15
hours a week you end up completing the
program and if you don't get a job offer
within six months after that you get a
refund of your program fees so it builds
up your skills in Step ways fashion it
starts off with after the orientation
statistics
basic analytics techniques using Excel
and then SQL python
machine learning techniques Tableau for
visualization data reporting and then
Capstone which allows you to take all of
these different skills
and
put them together in a project that you
can then show off to employers as part
of your portfolio along the way you have
the ability to take that no extra charge
the electives and data science with r
and a deep learning so
those are all available to you and that
you follow the areas that are most
interesting to you you end up with a
certificate and you end up with the
guaranteed job within six months after
completing the program so if you uh
interview prep
help you rewrite your resume you get
access to a premium job board and then
one of our partner companies guarantees
that they will hire you so
um
this program again is only available in
India we have other programs that don't
include the job guarantee but I just
want to ask a quick question to the
audience if this is something based on
this really very very thumbnail sketch
I've just given you how many people out
there might be interested in a program
of this type
so I'm going to open this poll
and I'll just give you about 30 seconds
oops before I go to
the
audition
there
I'll give another about another 20
seconds
I know that we allow too much time for
these poles sometimes
because the questions are really
important
give time for the last few people to to
get their answers in
here we go
so uh
wow about half of the people are
definitely interested about 40 percent
are maybe interested so
uh we will give you information about
how you can contact us about that and
it's good to see that um
fifty percent of the respondents said
that they'd like to do it either right
away or within three months which is
still pretty much right away so I'm
going to put into the chat right now
um a couple of things number one I'm
going to put in
the link to that program page and how to
contact us about that I'm also going to
put in
[Music]
um
issues uh
LinkedIn
URLs that you have that available so
let's start off with
how to contact us you can look at the
data science program page at this URL
and also there's an email address to
contact us to ask the questions directly
and as far as
URL I'm putting that in as well so if
you're in the chat box
[Music]
and for those who are watching on
streaming if you do want to contact us
you can come to our website
simplylearning.com and look under the
data science category under all courses
but also you can
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
skus simplylearn.net
and with that I'd like to thank uh yeshu
for being here for being so generous
with your time and our knowledge
um so again thank you so much
thank you thank you Stuart it was nice
uh talking to everyone
and
um with that I'd like to invite everyone
to connect with us on our
and Twitter
close to the end okay follow us
[Music]
at a regular basis
and we thank you again for being here
today whether on WebEx or YouTube or
LinkedIn
um we really appreciate it and that
concludes our webinar for today so thank
you and goodbye
thank you
foreign
foreign